el presidente sudafricano civil ramaposa
se encuentra en el ojo de una tormenta
política e incluso podría llegar a ser
destituido Próximamente esto tras el
escándalo conocido localmente como Farm
Gate se trata de una acusación que se le
hace ramaposa de haber encubierto el
robo de 4 millones de dólares de su
granja en palapala en 2020
ramaposa está rechazando todas estas
acusaciones dice que no Eran cuatro
millones sino de 580.000 y que
respondían a la compra de unos Búfalos
sin embargo dos años más tarde los
búfalos que supuestamente fueron
comprados siguen en la granja y el
comprador un empresario sudanés no ha
aparecido tampoco tras la investigación
también se cuestiona por qué ramaposa
tendría este dinero escondido en un sofá
en su granja y porque el robo no se ve
reportó a la policía también se le acusa
incluso de haber dado cacería a los
ladrones para comprar su silencio y que
no reportaran a las autoridades el
parlamento sudafricano está entonces
estudiando la posibilidad de establecer
una moción de destitución para el
presidente su su sede apenas dos semanas
antes de la conferencia del CNA el
partido de gobierno que es el Congreso
Nacional africano en la que ramaposa
podría eh o bien ser religioso por otros
cinco años o bien caer si es destituido
y por completo manchar su reputación
ramaposa además subió el poder con una
Consigna anticorrupción tras los
escándalos que le costaron el puesto a
su predecesor Jacob suma se pone
entonces en tela de juicio la
credibilidad de ramaposa un antiguo
luchador combatiente por la libertad
quien además ayudó a redactar la
Constitución de la Sudáfrica democrática
después de la caída de la parte y un
Aliado cercano de Nelson Mandela se pone
entonces también en tela de juicio de la
credibilidad del propio partido de
liberación del CNA Qué es el partido
político de liberación más antigua del
continente